on Prime crime my husband's deceased
there's an interacting at my home he
stiff and he wounded he might have a
heart attack an unconventional
relationship ends in tragedy he bought
himself a drink really heavy and then he
started skewing realize how much rage
was going on in there leaving behind a
broken family and a wife facing serious
questions he would often say everything
will be okay as long as I hide the steak
knives oh my God he didn't hide the
steak knives
[Music]
hey everybody I'm Jesse Weber and
welcome to Prime crime this is where we
break down some of the most compelling
and memorable True Crime cases
marriages at times can be pretty Rocky
right from those little tips to the
serious arguments that's normal
yet the relationship in this story is
quite different it goes from a rather
unique beginning
to a deadly end
it's around 9 30 in the morning on
January 12 2019 when 9-1-1 dispatchers
receive a frantic call from a woman in
Winter Park Florida
I don't know
that's the voice of 45 year old Danielle
redlick who says she discovered her
husband 65 year old Michael redlick dead
on the floor of their home it was just a
bizarre case initially when she called
9-1-1 she said that her husband had
succumbed to a heart attack
but then she had a different story she
said that Michael stabbed himself to
death
she was in fear of her life
he was actually choking me and trying to
suffocate me first I actually went for
the knife and he was screaming
we grabbed it and that's when he did it
he made a motion face stabbed himself
and I ran into the bathroom when I came
out I thought it was flying in blood you
say hi there
correct yes
he tried to hurt myself this morning it
doesn't look good
in order to understand how we got here
we have to take a step back to the
unusual beginning of Danielle and
Michael's relationship I first met Mike
I think it was 1996. he'd come to the
golf course and say I think I'm in love
with this woman Kathleen but she's dying
of cancer I think I'm going to marry her
I'm going to marry her yeah the benefits
that she has are terrible she's going to
have better treatment better care and
that's why he
that's why he married um Kathleen
I'm sure they were in love but he was
all about helping her out
after Kathleen passed away Mike was
basically providing for two of
Kathleen's kids Danielle and her younger
brother Michael redlick was an executive
for various sports teams so he had a
prominent job doing well make good money
she found him somewhat exciting he was
20 years or senior certainly had more
financial resources and it sounds like
he was able to take around and do
different things with her
somewhere down the road the relationship
started he married his stepdaughter we
warned him against it like what are you
thinking in a weird way it's a love
story that most people wouldn't approve
of
but it became a love story a real love
story well that's the biggest mistake
Mike made in his life
fast forward 15 years Michael is dead
and Danielle is taken to the hospital to
be evaluated police pay her a visit to
try and piece together what exactly
occurred here we just kind of want to
get some type of information as to what
happened if you're willing to talk to us
that'd be good perfectly willing to see
what happens
at the hospital Danielle was concerned
about her kids and about herself she was
worried of what would happen to her and
who would tell the kids that Michael was
dead I'm really concerned about my kids
knowing that their dad's gone well who
tells them this my husband's gone
right and that you're in the hospital
under care
no details forming them at all
I didn't believe it was what struck me
was there were some times that she shed
some tears but I thought that she was
rather calm and cool and collected to be
in that situation where are people being
cold and we haven't talked to anyone we
wanted to talk to you first if you're
willing to talk to us I mean I'm
definitely willing I'm just afraid
should I have legal representation is
that no one's been telling me that's up
to you this may seem odd but it's the
police that are interviewing you so I
understand you say I'm not being held
but the doctors are evaluating my not
being held by the police department
but the hospital
correct you know it seems like a normal
question but she did ask if I was free
to leave am I under arrest right so she
must have known that there was some
suspicion yet there is much more to
Michael and Danielle's relationship
accusations and allegations you want me
to describe what happened
Thursday my husband was very belligerent
and distraught well at first the
relationship was fine but then over time
there are allegations of controlling
behaviors and that he had a drinking
problem
he was following me in around the house
I was trying not to engage I locked
myself in the bathroom he broke the door
open he was scaring me so I decided to
leave and he was drinking heavily I'm
not a rocket scientist but wait a minute
there's eight empty bottles of wine in
the garbage Mike didn't like wine
so
those bottles got empty by somebody
other than Mike
we had some issues last year he
basically cheated on me and it was a big
long john thing and I found a slew of
emails of him carrying on with another
woman that just crushed me Mike was
trying to understand and he must have
been going to some meetings with Alan on
and along the way he met a woman they
became friends
friends it was somebody that he could
talk to about dealing with her no
infidelity at all on Mike's part I'm
convinced of that
from another man to me that really
angered him Danielle had social media
messages and it was kind of right in the
middle of where these communications
were social nature or was she looking
for employment she alluded to the fact
that she was looking to further her
career and it sounds like he was
somewhat jealous that she also was
interested in other men Thursday I ended
up leaving the home to avoid any kind of
distresses for the kids my daughter the
two of them were yelling at each other
and I said okay that's it we're leaving
with me to a friend's house and my son
wanted to see he was belligerent but he
wasn't being physically harmful to the
kids that's where things began to go
somewhat awry in the marriage she
complained that as a result he was both
physically and emotionally abusive and
unfortunately we live in this Society
where domestic violence still occurs and
we're not so quick to disbelieve a woman
who is smaller than her husband
at his funeral
Danielle delivered the eulogy and told
everyone in the congregation
that Mike was her best friend and talked
about all the things that he had done
for her and the kids
no way if you listen to that eulogy you
could ever think that this guy would lay
a hand on her police need to get the
full story of how Michael redlick died
coming up can detectives figure out what
actually happened between the couple I
did not murder my husband please I don't
understand this is a tragedy
[Music]
everyone in the congregation at his
funeral is looking at her delivering a
eulogy and they're all saying the same
thing why isn't she Behind Bars
it's January 2019 and 45 year old
Danielle redlick is being questioned
after calling 9-1-1 saying her
stepfather turned husband 65 year old
Michael redlick died in their Winter
Park Florida home
after telling dispatchers several
versions of what happened investigators
talked to Danielle at the hospital where
she says Michael was aggressive and
intimidating he continued on his day
Friday to work
and I continued my day I got some style
texts from him during the day
we attend our son's football game
together that evening and it was after
the football game we're once again he
poured himself a drink and a really
heavy and it just started from there he
started spewing realized electric rage
was going on in there she had previously
filed a police report against Michael
for domestic abuse and because of that
it led krenas to her claim later that
she was in fear of her life and then
Michael was at it again but Danielle
starts to shut down I think that's about
what I was comfortable talking about
currently with Danielle not giving
police much to go on days later they
returned to the redlick's home this time
with a warrant in hand
Daniel I just want to talk to you okay
right now you're not under arrest but we
just secured you for our safety we do
have a search warrant for your house and
I also have a search warrant for your
DNA while the detective collects the DNA
sample Danielle seems shocked to learn
what investigators may be thinking two
bugle swabs saliva standards from
Danielle Justine redlick which is
believed to be evidence relevant to
proving that a felony crime has been
committed death investigation second
degree murder are located in the person
you're saying the saliva when I tried to
when there was resuscitation done that
that second degree murder
no I'm collecting saliva standards from
you because of the resuscitation because
of other evidence that we have
collected she also said that she tried
to save Michael's Life Giving Him CPR
and passed out because of her Herculean
efforts she tried CPR and couldn't find
her phone to call 9-1-1
hmm
dancing dancing and just changing the
story as much as she could so you're
saying that once this DNA is confirmed
his mind I'm being charged a second
degree murder is that what I'm hearing
that's not what I'm saying
I'm saying I'm collecting this
to be tested on what we collected from
the house we need to be able to
differentiate your DNA from your
husband's CNA that's when Danielle
starts getting defiant
I don't understand this it's not even
freaking happened I don't understand
what are you
you tell me what they're looking for
is that a no we also have a search
warrant to collect any other evidence
that we think is necessary I'm trying to
Target
I did not murder my husband please I
don't understand
from what I understand you live directly
across the street from the Red Lake
correct little did Danielle know there
were others who for a long time noticed
issues between her and Michael issues
that become critical in understanding
the complexity of this case the whole
neighborhood knows that they fought
verbally at least and physically out in
front of the house police speak with the
redlick's neighbors and learn even more
about the tumultuous relationship we are
very aware of the decorating in fighting
and that type of thing most of the time
with the screening of one another but
primarily it was her screaming at him
these are two people that were not
getting along the relationship started
off in a very strange Manner and they
probably should have never been together
in the first place when you hear them
fighting outside did you ever hear the
nature of what they were arguing about
or just kind of little bits and pieces
oh I think a couple times she'd scream
get out of here or that type of thing
but not to the extent of what where the
issue was he knew she represented not
only a danger to him
but to herself
and I I think when you mix alcohol and
anger management
she had a couple altercations with the
law so my guess is he was just trying to
keep her in check I didn't see any
altercation with hitting but my wife has
also on occasion her hitting him I don't
know whether he's hit her or whatever
the scenario was from that standpoint
s has it been verbal or physical but it
wasn't on his part so she's initiated it
or she's been yelling okay when it's
physical what have you seen
her slapping him around in the face
some of us saw
some dangers there if you would have
asked me six years ago
did I have any friends whose spouse
were capable of killing them I'd say
only one and that would be Danielle
how would you describe Michael
he always seemed very laid-back I never
saw any kind of aggression or anything
and how would you describe Daniel
volatile but I don't know what happened
behind closed doors then detectives
learn there's been run-ins with the red
licks in the past including the year
earlier when Michael actually called
9-1-1 on Danielle
we need a car here there's a woman at
the danger herself into others right now
my sense on call 9-1-1 was to show her
that look I'm not going to abuse you
I'm not going to hit you but I've had it
you better go in your room please Dance
please
stop all right I'll call I will call you
back I will call you back in five
minutes sir what is going on there
hello you can see in a domestic
situation where someone is looking at
their wife acting crazily that they
would call police and because they
didn't know what her intentions were
that they wouldn't ask police to come
over right away and said he would call
them back but he never did this was not
Danielle's first brush with the laws she
actually was uh previously charged with
getting into an altercation with a
couple of deputies she was even accused
of biting one of the deputies and she
received probation
it's still not clear though what truly
happened in the redlick's home that
January night when Michael died but up
next
investigators speak with someone else
who maybe can provide some answers she
was like when dad comes home he's angry
with me right now so if you like sense
tension I'm just warning you me and Dad
are on good terms right now
[Music]
oh
he started struggling about five years
or so but he started getting some
medical problems and Ed
UCA
remember this
whole shock
it's January 2019 and police set their
sights on Danielle redlick a woman on
probation as they think she stabbed her
husband Michael redlick to death all
amid a heated argument in the couple's
Winter Park Florida home over the
15-year marriage this relationship has
been Rocky for the stepdaughter turned
wife who says Michael 20 years her
senior physically and verbally abused
her police need to determine if there's
any truth to what Danielle is saying so
they speak with the redlick's son then
11 year old Sawyer to get a better
picture of what their family life was
like and what may have gone down the
night Michael died how did you get to
your friend's house yesterday
um I had a football game last night and
I had a sleepover with him was he
supposed to coach this morning at your
football
and he just didn't show up yeah
Mike was a little league coach and the
Knight of the occurrence there was a
flag football game how was your parents
relationship that night I think there
was some tension between them I don't
know why but
he's anger who appeared angry
you know if anybody was toxic in a
relationship it was Danielle
go back and look at all the things
before he came back into the house that
night what did she do to him as he was
getting out of the car
she threw eggs at the car
she egged her husband
this is not a sane woman
have they ever gotten into arguments
that you actually saw them physically
fighting yes they are pushing each other
have you ever seen anything more than
just pushing between the two of them
scratching okay oh it's scratch Hill
I guess my mom my dad would push away
investigators then learn even more about
Michael and Danielle's troubling
marriage from their daughter 15 year old
Jaden my parents used to be separated
they're obviously not divorced but
that's like a family we've been through
a lot this past year I know they were
kind of in a heated argument this week
about something Jaden's interview with
the police was what I would expect
basically that her parents did not get
along
my dad moved out in April of last year
and he moved back in in
I've always had like an off and on
relationship for like I think the past
five or six years it's interesting for
someone so young that's getting
information from both parties clearly
the father communicated to her that he
didn't necessarily get along with his
mother and the mother was communicating
to her that she didn't necessarily get
along with her father so she was kind of
stuck in the middle last year my dad met
this woman and my parents were separated
at that time and that was when they were
saying okay we're gonna get a divorce
and my mom like was really hurt by that
if you know the people close to both of
them Mike redlick was not the kind of
guy that was going to be cheating on his
wife no way
she had like an app on her phone not a
dating app she showed me the outfit was
for like work or something she had
messages where some the gentleman
mentioned that he found her attractive
and he liked her photo some random guy
was like flirting with her or something
but she didn't respond and my dad saw
that and I think that's what caused like
an argument I have a really close
relationship with my mom she told me
that she didn't have anything going on
with this guy obviously this was a
source of tension between her and her
husband at some point she even deleted
messages off of her phone these messages
certainly did not help her
you have mentioned they have fights in
the past has anything been physical at
points yeah
when's the last time you saw them there
until it feels like a confrontation
not for a while
sometime last year
Jayden blamed her mom for being an
instigator that if there was any
violence between them it was her mother
Danielle who instigated it in the times
in the past that they've had this
physical confrontation that you've
observed
who would be the market
I've never seen him hurt my mom like
physically
and it's rare for a daughter to point
the finger at her mother for being the
violent one but that's what happened
here the one time that I saw like a mark
on my dad's face was because they were
arguing and my mom had a ring on
has he ever hit her or left any marks on
her
I think so I remember just my mom saying
my dad pushed her do you think the push
was in self-defense because she was
coming at him or pushed because he was
upset at her
maybe both you had a verbal and physical
abuse being alleged you had cheating
being alleged so you had all this and a
combustible mix that led to the tragedy
that ensued he said to me on several
occasions everything will be okay as
long as I hide the steak knives I was
driving from Charlotte up to Cleveland
got a call from a good friend of mine
that let me know what happened they said
he was found dead I was in shock but at
the same time I wasn't surprised oh my
God he didn't hide the steak knives
detectives put two and two together and
they begin to realize that perhaps
Danielle's story that Michael stabbed
himself doesn't quite add up
maybe Danielle was the aggressor they
begin to build a case against her
starting with something police noticed
at the very start of this whole
investigation Michael was stabbed once
in the shoulder it was originally a
bloody crime scene but when
investigators walked into the house they
smelled disinfectant bleach it was clear
that the husband had bled out there was
evidence that she even attempted to
clean up by the time they arrived and
the fact that the wombs had dried it led
the investigators to believe that this
had taken place hours prior to her
calling 9-1-1
and let's go back to that 911 phone call
that Danielle made after the stabbing
there was one important detail that
caught investigators attention did you
just find him no actually it happened
last night did you see him last night
was he okay or was he was not okay last
night we had altercation what is
interesting of course is that she waited
11 hours to call the police after what
was ultimately discovered to be an
altercation between the two
her initial story was that he killed
himself
okay so if your husband kills himself
why wouldn't you call 9-1-1 right away
why would you tamper with evidence why
wouldn't she call EMS and see what she
could do to save him
about a week after the stabbing Danielle
is arrested for violating her probation
and that's when police press her even
further on Michael's staff
[Music]
tomorrow
for a lot of the other stuff yes
but with Danielle redlick not giving
into questioning it's the evidence that
starts doing the talking detectives
focused on the 11 hours where Danielle
said that she was hiding in the bathroom
because she was in fear of her life
meanwhile in those 11 hours she was
cleaning up the crime scene plus she was
surfing the web on a dating site looking
to meet new men while he's bleeding to
death that's the kind of stuff that
makes headlines and will stick in a
juror's mind to show that someone has a
cold and depraved heart
she did all types of odd behavior but I
just want to point out that it's not
absolutely dispositive because we all
react differently taking of a human life
is one of the most traumatic events that
one can engage in and it's very
difficult to know what normal behavior
is so kind of a mixed bag here about a
month after Michael redlick's death
Danielle is officially arrested and
charged with murder and tampering with
evidence Danielle was charted with
second-degree murder
which doesn't require premeditation it
could just be that she killed someone
with a depraved mind but didn't
necessarily plan in advance it's then
when Danielle is locked up in jail that
she does something which raises even
more suspicion
right
well it was basically they dropped the
charge to manslaughter 10 years
according to you know my lawyers it was
a good offer
but then today it seems like they had
bad news they're like well no the police
not he doesn't want to negotiate so you
know and now he wishes he didn't give it
to you most of us thought you know this
is an airtight case
and she's going to be found guilty if
anything maybe they let her plead out to
a lesser degree that offer was on the
table Danielle made the decision to
decline the manslaughter deal where she
would have served 10 years in prison
there's some evidence they keep getting
but it's just stuff they took out of his
desk when he was writing down stuff
about when I had filed for divorce
Michael was so angry he was keeping a
log of stuff like you know he was just
being vindictive like oh today Danielle
does this and it's like all this stuff
did to me I better not share too much
but there's something really bad about
him that he did when he was younger
they're trying to keep all that out she
obviously thought she could convince a
jury that she believes she was in fear
of her life she could use Michael's past
against him
big problem meanwhile this son of a is
drinking his ass off
smacking me around smacking the kids
around too go at it with me you know
well unfortunately a lot of people
aren't stepping forward because they
didn't see anything no one sees the
abuse you know I was mentally abused
like psychologically I'm not kidding you
sexually I mean he
oh boy he was a mastermind keep in mind
that even when one leads self-defense
they are not claiming that they did not
kill someone
they are merely saying I am not
criminally liable because I had to kill
this person in order to save my life
I was flipping on it so I use a towel so
they're saying you know that kind of
thing could be tampering so that's kind
of yeah the max for that is five years
alone she was also charged with
tampering when someone dies the police
have to conduct an investigation so it's
a crime to impede that investigation and
tamper with the crime scene when you
walk into a crime scene you smell bleach
generally that's tampering with the
evidence and so that's the one that all
along we knew she would be convicted of
the bigger question is would they get
her for murder
that's the question would a jury believe
Danielle redlick murdered her husband
they did a hell of a job banging up some
evidence a lot of us here say a neighbor
saw me hit him on the outside one time
if I go to trial I could definitely or I
could win when we return Danielle
redlick heads to trial
[Music]
to put a mother of our kids in jail
after her husband died it's fabulous
it's really great karma for you guys I
mean I know you're doing your job but at
the same time
I have had no chance for defense or
anything
in June 2022 prosecutors are set to
bring Danielle redlick's second-degree
murder in tampering with evidence case
before a jury for the death of her
stepfather turned husband Michael
redlick investigators believe Danielle
stabbed him after their 15-year marriage
turned to arguments and alleged abuse up
until now not much is clear of what
actually went on in their Suburban home
the day of Michael's death but it was at
trial where new details came to light
that defendant
plunged a knife into the shoulder
of Michael redlick which would cause him
to bleed to death
the home that she is standing in looks
like something from a horror movie the
prosecution's strongest evidence at
trial was the argument that manipulating
the crime scene hiding the crime
evidences a guilty mind
this defendant did everything she could
to avoid responsibility for her actions
the evidence will show that she engages
in a significant but failed attempt to
clean up the scene
Danielle's Alibi never made any sense
she only claims self-defense after she
first said that
Michael had a heart attack or that
Michael stabbed himself which is really
bizarre based on all the information
that you had from the 9-1-1 call your
conversation with Miss redlick did you
believe her to be claiming that Mr
redlick basically brought about his own
death yes did the autopsy results as
shared to you by the medical examiner
give you reason to believe that that was
not true yes Danielle kept changing her
story how can you dispute the fact that
he had someone who claimed to be a
victim of domestic violence who claimed
to be acting in self-defense who then
didn't claim self-defense when she spoke
to law enforcement
did you actually locate some evidence
yes I did there was towels that were
piled up next to the stair there was a
mop that had blood on it and a bucket
full of like pink liquid by the stairs
there was also knives there was a knife
in the doorway knives and the kitchen
sink
I think the prosecution relied more on
the physical evidence of her
manipulation of the crime scene than
anything else prosecutors also tried to
show evidence of problems in the
marriage an email from months before the
stabbing from Danielle to Michael was
particularly chilling
I know I'm bitter at times I admit but
you have a lot of nerve as well although
my words may be cutting they are only
sounds a Dull Knife compared to the
sharp disloyal deceiving phony and
never-ending selfish now if you continue
to twist in my back of course someone
would be messed up traumatized and may
act out she used a large knife to stab
Michael to death who then slowly bled
out for the next 11 hours it looked like
someone who wanted Michael dead and was
trying to hide her tracks then it comes
time for the defense to show jurors that
Danielle killed Michael in self-defense
everybody thought it would be a layup
but the one thing they were worried
about was how people would portray Mike
if I'm the defense attorney I'm going to
paint this story about this guy that
married a stepdaughter right we're going
to make him look like a predator that
was abusive
January 11 2019
someone was very very angry this someone
started to physically attack their
spouse they had rage
they were choking their spouse
smothering their spouse
that someone was Michael redlick and
Daniel radlich had no choice but to
defend herself because she was afraid
she was going to die
the other argument for self-defense is
that she stabbed Michael in the shoulder
it wasn't a Kill Shot you would normally
think of as an attempt to murder someone
would be in the heart
yes Danielle redlick did stab Michael
redlick Daniel rudlick knew and
recognized that the danger that she was
facing that night was different than the
other incidents of abuse that had
happened
throughout their marriage you can see
why jurors could buy the story that she
acted in self-defense because she had a
prior complaint of domestic violence
against Michael at one point during the
trial Danielle redlick takes the stand
herself telling the jury her version of
events the night Michael died so I like
on January 11th 2019 did you stab your
husband I did
yes she got to take the stand in her own
defense
and it was no one there to defend
Michael because Michael's dead
he was suffocating me I couldn't breathe
and he had me pinned down I was scared
and
um
you know it's just in fear for my life I
thought he snapped and I could die you
have any choice about to use a weapon to
get away no
she is
painting a story
that isn't true
she's using her manipulation to try to
convince the jury that she's the victim
I walked through the kitchen and that's
when he he comes up behind me
and grabs me
drip up on my feet and feet and follow
the ground
point I I grabbed the center Island and
I reach up to pull myself up to face him
grabs me here and slams me down onto the
Center Island counter there were times
when we say Mike now you you've never
hit her when she starts going off the
wall
his response was I just put my hands up
for self-defense
he called me
and he was holding my head
down on the counter so I'm just pinned
up against account like this and he's
straddling my body here and has me
pinned I've got a free arm here and um
the drawer in front of me is the only
thing I can do so I use my free arm to
push open the drawer ahead of me I think
he was just
trying to hold her back talk her down
off the ledge and she got carried away
and she killed him
pulled a knife out
Please Release my head
and I take the knife and I position it
and face it toward him he immediately
just goes to my chin and he pulls me
back and that's not stop him at that
point prior to stabbing him with a knife
are you able to remove yourself
no are you able to get out without using
a weapon
what are you trying to do
to get away from him
why
if you don't do that what is your belief
that will happen
that he might smother me to death
Danielle was the best witness for the
defense she abdicated for herself but
prosecutors still needed some questions
answered a life without Michael redlick
was a life that you were looking forward
to living
well life was at peace with Michael
redlick you wanted a life beyond Michael
correct
yes at that point yes
if a defendant can stand up against
cross-examination I think it can really
hurt the prosecution's case so you stood
in that home with the power to call for
help and you let your husband bleed to
death on that floor
you'd already bled to death I was
wondering if I could recover him or
something which one is it is he dead or
you think it's possible if he could be
covered something would have to be done
immediately and so yes I thought perhaps
I should do that
so in these fleeting moments you think
Mr redlet can be saved you choose not to
save him
I wouldn't put it that way no
when someone Waits 11 hours to call
9-1-1 she was no longer in fear of her
safety when he was lying on the floor
bleeding to death
and yet she let him die while she was
surfing the web looking for dates
standing there having mopped up all that
blood
taking all these towels and soaked them
through with Michael's blood
you thought that it was possible he had
died of a heart attack
thought there was a possibility
did not believe that your husband had a
heart attack
well I was hoping too we're hoping not
in The Morbid sense that I wanted him
dead but
if you had a heart attack you wouldn't
have been responsible for his death yes
to an extent
juries I think are rather sophisticated
and I think that she really helped
herself by getting on the stand because
it provided her with an opportunity to
tell her story and to talk about the
tumultuous relationship and to explain
why she took all the actions that she
did
once the case was finally handed over to
the jury it took them just four hours of
deliberating to come back with a major
decision
find the
verdict as to count to we the jury find
the defendant guilty of tampering with
physical evidence
I was sad
I in in my opinion Justice wasn't served
and I couldn't believe she got away with
it you have to respect jury decisions
these are 12 men and women that give up
their time to do their civic duty and
I'm not in the habit of questioning a
jury's decision it's a very interesting
decision uh it's very interesting that
all these things can occur and someone
can clean up a crime scene after killing
another person and be acquitted of
murder it's not something that we see
often at all Danielle redlick Dodges a
conviction of second-degree murder but
is sentenced to almost a year in jail
for tampering with evidence with credit
for time served the jury decided not
necessarily she was innocent but the
jury decided that they didn't have
enough evidence that she was a murderer
Beyond any reasonable doubt so in the
end she bet on herself and she won
Mike made one mistake wasn't being a
good father wasn't being a good husband
I wasn't being good to Danielle's mother
he married his stepdaughter should have
never have done it we could go back in
time and talk him out of it I wish we
had that opportunity
with her jail sentence completed
Danielle redlick is released from
custody on 12 months probation
my focus is trying to be there for the
kids what would Mike want me to do
he'd want me to you know help take care
of his kids just thinking back of how
much pride he had in both of them he'd
be bragging about the kids got in arm or
how well Jaden was doing in school you
know I'm very proud of his kids and it
was just getting to know him before he
ever met Danielle he would come to our
house
and the way he treated my kids oh
my kids thought the world of him
there's still a little bit more to this
story so Danielle's daughter Jaden
absolutely ripped into her mother in a
letter to the court saying she wants
nothing to do with Danielle
she wrote quote you may all be fooled by
the incredible mask this woman presents
to you all but I am not and Jaden even
asked for a no contact order for her and
her brother Sawyer but it appears that
wasn't successful look the truth is the
jury they believed Daniel radlik's story
yes
but what's left in the wake of this
whole case is unfortunately a broken
family that's all we have for you here
on this episode of prime crime everybody
thank you so much for joining us and as
always stay safe
thank you
[Music]